[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur tv5 monde
pour face aux territoires vous en avez
l'habitude maintenant chaque jeudi et
puis en direct aussi en live comme on
dit sur ouest france.fr sur
nicematin.com et sur franceantilles.fr
avec le léger décalage horaire du aux
fuseaux horaires aujourd'hui ce matin
mon invité en seront 6 novembre c'est
manuel valls bonjour merci monsieur
prémices d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
la location l'allocution télévisée du
président de la république donc
mardi soir le chef de l'état
a annoncé des mesures sanitaires mais
aussi beaucoup défendu son bilan est ce
que vous trouvez
comme il l'a dit que la situation
s'améliore vraiment en france vous il ya
un effet rebond incontestable pourquoi
le nier après la chute de la de la
croissance et de l'activité économique
dans des conditions uniques que nous
n'avions jamais connu en plus au niveau
planétaire dû à la crise sanitaire il ya
un rebond et ce rebond est spectaculaire
parce que notre économie a été soutenue
évidemment par l'investissement public
que nous n'avions jamais connu et
évidemment aussi progressivement par les
fonds européens dont il ya une situation
qui en termes de croissance et d'emploi
s'est améliorée mais voudrait que c'est
que c'est la perception qu'en ont les
gens vraiment je pense que c'est très
contrastée mais que le sentiment
d'inégalité sociale territoriale le
sentiment d'injustice
le sentiment de ne pas profiter
suffisamment de ce retour de la
croissance sentiment de précarité au
niveau de l'emploi qui concerne des
territoires mais aussi populaires et les
classes moyennes
ce sentiment est encore profond ce qui
explique une forme d'insatisfaction
d'anxiété de peur et aussi de colère
dans notre pays point du pouvoir d'achat
est suffisamment prise en compte vous
travaillez sur une une médias
concurrents une radio le matin où les
questions de pouvoir d'achat sont sans
arrêt les questions des auditeurs et les
gens qui se lèvent tôt le matin la
france qui qui travaillent tôt comme
disait un de vos prédécesseurs
jean-pierre raffarin est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est suffisamment prises en
compte dans la perception qu'a le
présent de la république des choses je
crois par le gouvernement et par le
président république oui d'où les
mesures par exemple dans le domaine de
la de l'énergie de la prime emploi après
la crise la prime d'activité pardon
après la crise des défilés jaune mais il
y a incontestablement plus avec le
retour de l'inflation qui risque d'être
d'être durable parce qu'il ya il ya une
pénurie de matières premières y ait une
pénurie de de manoeuvre qui de main
d'oeuvre ce qui explique l'augmentation
des prix et donc de la vie chère parce
que c'est ainsi qu'il faut traduire
l'inflation il ya un problème de
salaires dans le pays et notamment dans
les bas salaires de tous ceux qui
gagnent en dessous de 2000 euros et ça
c'est un sujet qui doit être traité par
les entreprises par secteur privé dans
des négociations central d'une
conférence sociale ou par branches mais
il ya un sujet salaire et ce sujet va va
monter parce que et notamment dans les
grandes agglomérations mais pas
seulement les gens n'y arrive plus entre
l'augmentation du prix de gaz du gaz
laiterie cité du fioul il n'y arrive
plus et on sent des situations qui
concernent pas les plus pauvres mais ces
classes moyennes qui arrivent plus à
boucler les fins de mois et pour les
questions de santé de transport de
logement pour se nourrir cc c'est un
parfois un vrai drame pour les familles
une polémique qui a monté depuis
l'intervention du président l'appliquent
mardi c'est un président qui a placé des
annonces sanitaires lors de cette
allocution et qui termine au fond sur
une forme de deux meetings favorable à
son bilan vous l'avez vous l'avez
entendu sk pas un mélange des genres
aujourd'hui qui est moins acceptable que
ça n'était précédemment
oui bien sûr mais c'est inévitable ou
présent la public sent bien que la
campagne présidentielle a commencé
lui-même le se déclare pas mais on voit
bien qu'il est en train de préparer ce
moment puis comme tout est concentré
c'est vrai pour les candidats c'est vrai
pour le président la république sortant
autour de la figure du chef de l'état du
président public décide en tout cas qui
décideraient de tous donc il ya une
attente forte et lui-même cherche à être
dans ce débat public à occuper l'espace
comme on dit les utilise pas les moyens
de l'état au fond pour être candidat
avant la lettre l'impression que ce
n'est pas tout à fait le le premier et
il occupe cet espace ce qui ce qui moi
me marque c'est que je ne sens pas cette
réflexion non plus parmi ceux qui demain
veulent concourir à cette élection est
une forme de solitude non comme si le
chef de l'état le président république
je parle pas seulement des manuels
macron était seul face au peuple et moi
j'y vois dans la situation politique
d'aujourd'hui où il ya plus de grands
partis ou les corps intermédiaires sont
très affaiblis où il ya la colère il ya
du populisme où il ya du dégagisme comme
on dit je vois des dangers pour notre
démocratie je sens que la manière dont
il faudrait gouverner le pays la manière
dont il faudrait bâtir des grandes
coalitions ces sujets là ne sont pas
assez présents dans le débat public
c'est manuel valls en ce 11 novembre
l'ancien premier ministre est notre
invité politique d'en face aux
territoires vous ne serez pas candidat à
l'élection présidentielle manuel valls
est sûre je crois pas non plus bien
évident voilà dans un instant on démarre
cette première partie territoire avec la
présence sur ce plateau de stéphane bern
et de ouest france
[Musique]
bonjour stéphane bern et bonjour la vous
êtes rédacteur en chef délégué du
premier quotidien francophone du monde
merci d'être présent sur ce plateau dans
un instant nous allons questionner
ensemble manuel valls met tout de suite
françois xavier le franc le rédacteur en
chef de ouest france à une question à
poser à manuel valls on écoute ce sont
des images de l'or saubade manuel valls
bonjour l'hôpital français ne va pas
bien l'hôpital est en crise l'hôpital
manque de moyens manque de postes manque
de médecins et ces jours-ci beaucoup de
services d'urgence sont sous pression
maximum car évidemment nous vivons une
crise sanitaire exceptionnelle mais nous
manquons de médecins en france et depuis
dix ans depuis 20 ans depuis trente ans
on nous dit que ce problème ne peut pas
se régler facilement parce que pour
former un médecin il faut dix ans
seulement ça fait bientôt trente ans
qu'on nous dit ça donc comment fait-on
aujourd'hui quelles sont vos
propositions pour l'hôpital sachant que
sur l'ensemble des territoires français
ce sujet là est vraiment un sujet de
préoccupation majeur oui ça sujet
préoccupation majeure parce que si
l'hôpital public si l'ensemble des
personnels de santé ont été formidables
en première ligne face à la crise
sanitaire pas soko vides il y à une
fatigue et tous les sujets d'avant qui
n'ont pas été suffisamment traité il
faut il prendre tous notre part
collectif faut se rappeler qu'il ya
seulement quelques années nous vivions
c'était mon cas comme premier ministre
sous la pression des déficits publics en
fin du niveau déficit public va pas de
la pression seulement de la commission
européenne ou de ceux qui surveillaient
les comptes de la france mais y compris
de la part de l'opinion publique un
candidat comme françois bayrou en 2007
notamment avait porté sa campagne sur le
fait que nos déficit public ou sociaux
donc la situation de nos hôpitaux ces
déficits était insupportable qu'il
fallait y remédier mais
incontestablement n'y a pas eu
suffisamment une prise en compte de
cette situation et aujourd'hui ça craque
de partout je suis frappé par non
seulement le nombre de lits fermés même
si une polémique sur sur sur le chiffre
mais sur les démissions parce que de
médecins est évidemment d'infirmiers et
d'infirmières parce que là une situation
difficile donc il faut continuer de
recruter ce qui on a fait sauter le
numerus clausus avec marisol touraine
qui était ministre de la santé nous
avions déjà élevé ce numerus clausus une
vingtaine de pourcent mais c'est vrai
c'est long il faut former des médecins
il faut rendre le métier plus attractif
notamment pour les autres personnels
donc c'est l'augmentation des salaires
et c'est les suites du ségur de la santé
et on n'échappe pas de toute façon y
compris pour des questions de qualité de
soins et de sécurité à poursuivre la
réorganisation de l'hôpital plus les
soins ambulatoires ambulatoire plus le
fait que ce pays n'a pas suffisamment
fait le choix de la prévention etc la
prévention qui nous permet aussi de le
prévenir une maladie et de faire des
économies il ya un autre aspect possible
des choses c'est une réorganisation
générale des soins en france vous avez
les régions par exemple qui demandent à
pouvoir piloter les agences au co piloté
les agences régionales de santé est ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée
oui moi je pense que dans le domaine de
la santé dans le domaine de de l'hôpital
même s'il faut la schéma national il
faut des politiques publiques puissante
au niveau de la france il faut là aussi
permettent me semble-t-il aux
collectivités territoriales pour ce qui
concerne l'hôpital ce sont sans doute
les régions qui sont financièrement les
mémés armée plus pour avoir une vision
d'ensemble avec les grandes régions oui
il faut incontestablement là cela fait
parti me semble-t-il des nouvelles
compétences des dévolutions que peuvent
assumer les collectivités territoriales
et donc pour l'hôpital ça me sourit
compris pour la rénovation pour la
réalisation pour la proximité pour la
gestion des territoires qui manque
aujourd'hui de pitau ou des hôpitaux qui
sont obligés de fermer parce qu'il
suffit qu'un médecin partent pour qu'un
plateau technique ferme oui ce sont les
régions là je pense que cela fait partie
des nouvelles compétences plus
généralement il ya une attente dans ce
pays autour de la décentralisation de
nouvelles compétences donner aux régions
et aux collectivités qu'elle regarde que
vous portez sur le la loi dite 3ds
différenciation décentralisation
déconcentration et simplification qui
reviendra à l'assemblée en descendre
elle permet là aussi une nouvelle étape
en matière de compétences je ne crois
pas qu'elles règlent la tente des
français calmement la grande loi
désignant et surtout ne règle pas la
confusion ou sans doute que vivent
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui ont du
mal à s'y retrouver dans ce qu'on
appelle le minivan
trop de collectivités c'est le fils il
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on con qu'on
s'attaque à ce sujet là il ya forcément
une réaction des uns les autres je
considère que l'un de nos échecs en 2012
c'est alors que la gauche gouvernait le
pays avait tous les pouvoirs présidence
de l'assemblée nationale sénat et bien
sûr la plupart des collectivités
territoriales n'y a pas une vision
d'ensemble nous permettent de nous
attaquer aux sujets dont je pense que
sur les compétences de la santé nous
voulons de le dire sur l'emploi pôle
emploi la formation même si beaucoup a
été fait le développement économique il
faut clarifier les compétences et qui
fait quoi au fond les régions on voit
bien on la stratégie l'économie la santé
les départements les questions sociales
l'intercommunalité les communes la
réalité locale je ne suis pas sûr que
nous soyons obligés de passer par la
suppression d'une collectivité mais une
clarification et des compétences
nouvelles assumé par les collectivités
oui incontestablement et l'idée de
nicolas sarkozy qui était d'avoir un
conseiller territorial commun entre les
le même élu qui soit à la fois à la
région et au département c'était une
bonne idée finalement j'ai mis en oeuvre
ne pas être hypocrite et est dans une
contradiction permanente j'ai mis en
oeuvre la décision du président la
république annoncé d'ailleurs d'avant
les français
de ne pas mettre en oeuvre de le
conseiller dans les pures yalouz progrès
moi j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
de ce point de vue là les français
élisent le fameux binôme au conseil
départemental et vote sur des listes
régionales je pense pas que ce soit le
problème principal surtout si nous
gardons le même niveau de collectivités
territoriales toujours dans le rapport
au territoire j'aimerais avoir votre
votre votre regard ou votre réaction sur
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
qui concernait le l'apprentissage en
immersion des langues régionales vous
avez l'exemple catalan vous avez votre
expérience comment comment vous vous
avez perçu cette décision et est ce que
c'est un mauvais coup fait aux faits aux
territoires aux régions de jus désolé de
le dire notamment aux journalistes de
ouest france que mon expérience j'étais
pendant trois ans à barcelone
réflexion sur aussi les défis du pays et
ses déchirures
territoriale nidifier les différentes
formes de séparatisme qui guette les
pays européens je généralise m'ont amené
à être au fond jose la provocation assez
jacobins et telle est la france c'est
une cellule c'est un vieil état c'est la
plus est le plus avec l'angleterre plus
vieil état nation
la nation française s'est construit à
travers l'état qui est sa colonne
vertébrale et donc je suis très attentif
à tout ce qui pourrait défaire notre
pays aille bien sûr il faut déconcentrer
décentralisée faire confiance aux
acteurs locaux mais il faut garder cette
unité de ce point de vue là la langue
est très importante autant je crois au
développement et la promotion des
langues régionales en revanche pour ce
qui concerne l'enseignement la colonne
vertébrale de l'enseignement je suis
très défavorable à ce qu'on appelle
l'immersion se comportent pas les
situations espagnole et française bien
évidemment mais non là je pense que
l'éducation nationale qui ne va pas bien
l'apprentissage de la langue qui pour
moi essentiel doivent d'être des
priorités c'est une bonne chose pour un
dirigeant politique de haut niveau qui
aspirent à l'être d'aller avoir une
expérience en europe par exemple de
quelques années avant de revenir en
france ça fait changer les perspectives
en tout cas ça a changé ma vie moi j'en
avais besoin je l'expliquais dans un
dans un livre que j'ai publié il ya
quelques mois j'avais ce besoin de de
partir pour des raisons personnelles mon
couple était en train de se défaire pour
des raisons politiques aussi parce que
dans l'exercice du pouvoir notamment
face au terrorisme je sentais une forme
de fatigue parce qu'un monde était en
train de se défaire celui de ma famille
politique que je quittais à ce moment là
je veux parler du parti socialiste je
sentais ce besoin de pâtes donc ça a été
une expérience dans la ville où je suis
né il ya bien longtemps à barcelone
c'était une expérience forte
intéressante mais surtout ce que j'ai
retenu c'est que la france me manquait
c'est que j'étais profondément français
que c'est une valeur était française
donc j'ai eu besoin de ce recul si cela
était nécessaire pour me sortir encore
davantage français je vous ramène à
l'actualité des territoires la semaine
prochaine on l'a congrès de
l'association des maires de france
est-ce que vous irez non j'ai d'abord je
n'ai pas été invité je ne suis plus je
ne sais plus ce sera peut-être le cas
après l'émission plus l'air avec avec en
plus c'était un moment c'est toujours
été un moment important j'étais maire
pendant 11 ans maire d'evry
comme ministre de l'intérieur comme
premier ministre et assister à des
congrès on sent ces profonds ils y
achètent chaque français et je me sens
concerné quelque chose de rural de
pastorale il y a un lien au territoire
qui ont beaucoup évolué métropole
aujourd'hui évidemment sont très
importantes de leurs c'est bien là le
problème comment les métropoles gère ces
territoires notamment les territoires
périurbains et ruraux qui se tissent en
décrocher par rapport à la croissance à
la mondialisation ou à l'europe c'est là
on sent de la crainte de l'anxiété par
rapport à l'avenir de la part de dd des
couches moyennes en tout cas de ceux qui
habitent dans ses dents danse et auxerre
c'est une résonance de ce qui se passe
dans le pays il faut écouter ce qui
représente c'est 36 milner qui sont
aussi la sève de notre de notre pays
c'est une association fondamentale vous
avez sans doute suivi le la le les
tiraillements autour de la succession de
françois baroin entre philippe laurent
et david lisnard de deux mères qui
veulent reprendre la la tête la
présidence de l'association est ce que
quelqu'un le regard vous portez sur 7
sur ce il ya une vraie compétition après
notamment la présidence de françois
baroin qui était incontesté et
incontestable
je me mêle plus de ça d'abord parce que
j'ai du recul et puisque je ne suis plus
est lui élu local mais bon ça veut dire
c'est une association importante qui à
la compétition des heureux ceux qui sont
candidats à la présidence de
l'association des maires de france je
les connais bien et sont ils sont et ce
sont des gens de très grande qualité moi
je pense de plus en plus que dans le
champ républicain il y à des
personnalités des hommes des femmes des
mères des politiques de terrain qui ont
des très grandes qualités qui sont faits
pour travailler ensemble regardez la
liste du maire de cannes david lisnard
avec andré laignel qui est l'inamovible
numéro 2 de l'association des maires de
france socialiste depuis des années
tenir cette association à moins de six
mois de la présidentielle c'est c'est
important ça peut avoir une grosse
influence je pense que ce sera une
influence pour après deux tours à son
parce que l'association représente tous
les maires de france mais dans l' écoute
ce qui a manqué au cours de ce
quinquennat notamment dans la première
partie des corps intermédiaires des élus
locaux ce sont des associations c'est
une association celle des élus locaux
des mers particulièrement important
manuel valls eux vous auriez des
ambitions à nouveau municipale d'être un
élu local ça vous paierez jeu je ne
crois pas parce que c'est une il faut
moi ça a été le c'est le plus beau des
mandats alors celui de la deûle à
proximité j'ai d'ailleurs j'aime pas
beaucoup l'expression hauteur de bave
noah à hauteur de 2,2 citoyens et cette
proximité puis surtout parce que ce
qu'on décide on le voit ce serait quoi
non alors pourquoi nous parce que je
pense qu'il faut avoir le goût l'envi le
temps l'énergie et c'est plus le cas la
volonté des deux noms puisque je les
fais déjà et donc je n'aspire pas à
refaire ce que j'ai fait quand j'étais
plus jeune c'était formidable place aux
autres on n'est pas irremplaçable mais
évidemment maire d'evry c'était
incontestablement pour moi le plus beau
des dvd des mandats voilà c'est une
tradition dans cette émission un dessin
par un dessinateur de ouest-france qui
s'appelle chaunu à une question à vous
poser sous forme de dessin d'ailleurs on
vous donnera le dessin après on regarde
on écoute juillet
monsieur le premier ministre si une
partie des écoliers a remis le masque
pour la rentrée ou là le conseil de
l'europe lui a retiré illico presto sa
campagne de promotion du hidjab le voile
suite à la vague de protestations
qu'elle a déclenchées dont la vôtre
alors la question que je pose quelle
stratégie
adopter pour que la france ne soit plus
inaudible dans le monde lorsqu'elle
défend son modèle si singulier de
république laïque une et indivisible
ces questions très juste parce que c'est
vrai que sur ces sujets là c'est à dire
une conception universelle
des valeurs universelles qui sont que ça
évidemment la révolution française mais
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes la lutte contre les
communautarismes la séparation des
églises et de et de l'état la france a
une voix originale mais parfois un peu
un peu seul nous luttons aujourd'hui il
faut bien se rendre compte contre n'ont
pas l'islamisme seulement bien
évidemment et cette idéologie mortifère
mais aussi contre ce qu'on appelle là
quand cette culture le haut qui me fait
bref une vision qui nous vient
d'amérique il y a trente ou quarante ans
on parlait de l'impérialisme américain
jovial impérialisme culturel qui
s'immisce un peu un peu partout donc
c'est important que la france réussisse
à convaincre en europe que ses thèses
qui consiste par exemple à nous
expliquer que une femme voilée c'est la
liberté alors qu'il ya des femmes qui
arrachent leur boil en afghanistan ou en
iran que le voile c'est un symbole de
soumission de la femme très important de
convaincre les autres pays d'où le fait
qu'il fallait stopper cette cette
campagne merci stéphane bern et de
ouest-france rédacteur en chef délégué
dans un instant denis carot nous rejoint
sur ce plateau pour une nouvelle partie
de cette émission à tout
[Musique]
une partie consacrée aux questions plus
régaliennes denis carot bonjour merci
vous êtes directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin donc eux aussi var
matin bien sûr et dans un instant c'est
à vous pour rejoindre cyril gautier qui
se trouve donc à fort de france il
bouquet c'est le directeur des
rédactions du groupe france antilles
manuel valls partenaires de cette
émission également on écoute bonjour
manuel valls en ce 11 novembre une
question à propos des forces armées il
ya un certain nombre de régiments ou de
détachement qui sont stationnées
outre-mer comment envisagez-vous le rôle
qui pourrait avoir en matière de
coopération notamment avec le bassin
géographique qui est entouré chacun de
ces territoires alors pour les antilles
bien sûr et karim et pour la guyane le
continent américain oui et d'ailleurs la
france aujourd'hui à travers la la force
la richesse malgré les défis et les
problèmes qu'ils connaissent mais la
force et les richesses de le territoire
et de nos compatriotes ultramarins
rayonne sur les cinq continents donc
donc c'est particulièrement important
que ces territoires restent prioritaires
et le rôle des forces armées ou des
forces de sécurité de ce point de vue là
essentiel j'ai d'ailleurs quand j'étais
ministre l'intérieur je considérais que
nous n'étions pas au niveau et même s'il
ya eu des améliorations
cela ne reste pas au niveau notamment
aux caraïbes en guyane dans la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue contre tous
les formes de trafic qui existent qui
sont particulièrement dangereux et qui
sont les trafics qui vont vers l'europe
et qui nous oblige donc à des
coopérations régionales bien plus
puissantes et à une meilleure présence
de nos forces armées de nos forces de
sécurité sur ces territoires pour
protéger nos concitoyens sur place et
pour lutter contre ces trafics mis ko
bonjour manuel valls il y a 6 ans la
france étaient frappées par les
attentats du 13 novembre
aujourd'hui le risque terroriste est
toujours aussi élevée que doit-on faire
de plus ou de différent en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme il faut
poursuivre ce qui a été engagé
l'améliorer en permanence quand je dis
améliorer s'améliorer faire évoluer
quand c'est nécessaire notre législation
évidemment continue de donner des moyens
à nos forces de sécurité à nos services
de renseignement ça c'est ce travail qui
qu'il faut faire et nous voyons bien que
la menace a changé a muté pour l'instant
et notamment qu'elle est davantage
intérieur endogène et que des individus
peuvent frapper à tout instant
radicaliser comme on dit porter par
cette idéologie de mort donc il faut
être particulièrement vigilant et je
veux saluer évidemment le travail des
policiers et les gendarmes mais le ski
me semble presque le plus important nous
venons de le dire d'une certaine manière
il ya un instant c'est de mener la
bataille politique culturelle
philosophique et de logique contre
l'islamisme contre l'islam politique
contre les frères musulmans contre les
salafistes c'est ça qui me paraît être
essentiel ce point de vue là le discours
du présent à public aux mureaux en 2020
a marqué un tournant dans le quinquennat
fait rejoindre les thèses qui étaient
les miennes et défendu depuis longtemps
sur cette bataille contre
l'islamisme et contre la guerre que nous
mène l'islam politique est une guerre
culturelle qui est une guerre de
civilisation puisqu'il s'agit pour eux
de s'attaquer à ce que nous sommes nous
français une grande nation républicaine
laïque mais aussi une terre chrétienne
juive
une terme marquée par le mélange mais
aussi par l'accomplissement de ces
valeurs universelles que j'évoquais il y
a un instant donc c'est une bataille
frontale et il faut l'amener partout à
l'école dans les services sociaux dans
nos territoires est-ce que ce terrible
épisode du 13 novembre vous a changé
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure une forme
de fatigue liée notamment au terrorisme
oui bien bien sûr parce que d'abord on
ont fait la différence entre entre ce
qui est essentiel est ce qu'il n'est pas
parce que nous vivons nous vivions à ce
moment là et le président avec bernard
cazeneuve le miz l'intérieur avec cette
angoisse permanente pas pour nous mais
pour les français de risque terroriste
parce que la menace extérieure est
encore plus puissant parce que les
groupes de deux dash étaient mieux
organisés c'était avant la fin du
califat et nous avions déjà cette menace
intérieure rappelons-nous de du terrible
attentat de de nice 14 juillet
1016 oui ça m'a changé sa masse en
dotant durci
ça m'a marqué de toute façon oui bien
évidemment comme cela a marqué les
français mais moi je pense j'y pense en
permanence et je pense d'abord je le dis
à chaque fois aux victimes parce que ce
sont elles les familles des victimes
elles mêmes qui vivent avec avec ces
attentats est ce que le procès qui a
lieu en ce moment à porte de vos points
de vue les réponses attendues je pense
qu'il est indispensable
ils utilisent tous très belle
démonstration par ailleurs de ce qu'un
état de droit et du respect du rôle de
la justice et puis pour les victimes
leurs familles c'est très important et
cela participe d'une manière ou d'une
autre à la manifestation de la vérité
des faits c'est manuel valls et l'ancien
premier ministre qui est notre invité en
ce moment ce novembre dans face aux
territoires manuel valls laurent martin
de frémont qu'a rencontré dylan meiffret
de nice matin à une question à vous
poser ça concerne vous allez voir la
réponse pénale à l'agression des
policiers
monsieur valls bonjour les policiers
nationaux de l'hexagone souffrent d'un
véritable manque de réponse pénale dès
lors qu'ils sont victimes de violence et
notamment de violences volontaires sur
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique partagez vous ce sentiment
monsieur et si oui de votre point de vue
comment y remédier
bien évidemment que je partage ce
sentiment les policiers sont en première
ligne nous l'avons vu il ya encore
quelques jours à cannes face à toutes
les formes de de menaces mais aussi au
quotidien parce que nous vivons dans une
époque où la mise en cause de l'autorité
du policier du gendarme du sapeur
pompier celui qui incarne l'autorité à
travers l'uniforme des élus aujourd'hui
mais aussi des parents du terrain de
manière à un affaissement de l'autorité
mais on s'attaque et on passe à l'acte
avec une violence inouïe vis-à-vis de ce
qui représente l'ordre aux solutions
donc moi je pense qu'il faut continuer
et il faut aussi le si c'est nécessaire
je le crois renforcer les sanctions à
l'égard de ceux qui s'attaquent aux
forces de l'ordre s'attaquer à un
policier un gendarme un soldat un
sapeur-pompier qui ont un élu qui
représente l'autorité républicaine
s'attaquer mérite une sanction
aujourd'hui plus forte il ya une
véritable dérive depuis le double
assassinat de magnanville on voit que
les policiers sont devenus des cibles au
delà de la réponse pénale des sanctions
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour protéger
davantage ce qui nous protège ce sont
les laits les équipements aujourd'hui
dodo commissariat de nos brigades de
gendarmerie regardez à cannes le seul
fait que les policiers portaient
ce qu'ils désavouent verbal c'est ce qui
les a sauvés
l'utilisation
des armes et ça a été fait face à sept
agresseurs non je pense que les les il
faut que les policiers se sentent
soutenus protéger je crois que c'est le
cas par les autorités de l'état par la
pop par les populations autant quand il
ya un policier qui dérive qui commet un
acte qui n'a rien à voir et la
déontologie qui prononce des mots
racistes il doit être sanctionné autant
nous devons être extrêmement ferme non
seulement dans leur protection mais
vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui nous
expliquent aujourd'hui ça vient parfois
aussi des états unis mais d'abord de
notre sol que notre police justice
sont racistes ne respecte pas les droits
de l'homme nous devons être
intransigeant dans la défense de notre
police républicaine a beaucoup parlé des
policiers nationaux il ya les polices
municipales qui se renforcent un peu
partout il y en a une qui vient d'être
créé à paris est ce qu'on doit renforcer
leurs prérogatives et est-ce qu'elles
doivent être systématiquement armés je
crois que j'ai quand j'étais maire j'ai
organisé une police municipale on la
comparait beaucoup avec celle de nice on
comparer celle de nice avec celle d'evry
avec de la vidéo surveillance des moyens
importants une police municipale armée
je pense que d'ailleurs dans les dents
les évolutions des des compétences pour
tout ce qui concerne la proximité moi je
crois important que progressivement nous
ayons des polices municipales dans
toutes les villes de plus de 10 mille ou
plus de vingt mille habitants mais avec
les moyens d'une police et un policier
aujourd'hui doit être protégée et doit
être armé d'ailleurs les policiers
municipaux ne dit pas suffisamment sont
particulièrement bien formés
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin demandé hier aux préfets de
renforcer la sécurité autour des élus
locaux et des parlementaires on voit que
les agressions se multiplient comment
vous analysé cette cette dérive c'est
cette mise en cause que je viens
d'évoquer de de l'autorité à l'arrêt une
grande philosophe il ya bien longtemps
avait déjà évoqué la mise en cause de
l'autorité ce sont des évolutions de
deux de nos sociétés c'est bien trop
long à expliquer mais cette mise en
cause de l'autorité c'est peut-être
aujourd'hui ce qui m'inquiète le plus
donc le rôle des responsables politiques
et du donc c'est le climat aujourd'hui
peut-être de notre campagne électorale
que je veux évoquer nécessite me semble
t'il de 2,2 de gouverner autrement de
faire respecter davantage cette autorité
nos comportements individuels et
collectifs je parle des responsables
publics doit être à la hauteur de ce que
demandent nos concitoyens mais le
respect de l'autorité républicaine et du
rôle de chacun d'une certaine manière
trop souvent le politique a oublié qu'il
avait une mission importante qui était
de représenter le peuple il a voulu
parfois se mettre à la hauteur de tout
le monde non un responsable politique
n'est pas tout à fait normal il
représente le peuple il est sous le
mandat du peuple mais du coup d'une
certaine manière son rôle est sacrée
justement sur les hauts responsables
politiques vous avez évoqué lors des
entretiens de nice organisé il ya trois
semaines par à par nice matin vous avez
regretté qu'on ne fasse pas davantage
appel à l'expérience et aux compétences
des anciens présidents de la république
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait les
utilisateurs verges et complété la
question appel aux compétences des
anciens premiers ministres et ses amis
sont bien plus nombreux alors que les
antilles après vrai public il serait
d'ailleurs dans quelques minutes aux
cérémonies du 11 novembre absolument et
c'est important parce que c'est celle
rappelle celle c'est le symbole de 2 de
ceux qui ont sacrifié leur vie pour
notre liberté
oui bah conservez vous utilisent pas
plus avec l'espagne où on parle des
présents la public moi je suis de ceux
qui considèrent que par exemple nicolas
sarkozy a bien fait les choses face à la
crise financière de 2008 qu'évidemment
le président la république françois
hollande a tenu bon et nous avons tenu
bon avec lui face au terrorisme que
emmanuel macron a pris des décisions
difficiles et courageuse face à la crise
sanitaire j'en ai un peu assez de ce
débat qui consiste à démolir en
permanence les uns et les autres je
regrette même d'une certaine manière le
sort qui est réservé à nicolas sarkozy
dans les affaires de justice et je pense
que leur expérience et je réponds à vos
questions l'autre expérience ça ne veut
pas dire forcément à des fonctions mais
doit être utile au fond en 2017 on a
assisté espèce de nouveau mon nom qui
devait tout changer non on voit que
c'est plus compliqué que cela et on a
besoin des uns et les autres et moi je
suis très favorable à ce que de mon ami
jacques julliard grand écrivain grand
intellectuel de gauche écrivait il ya
quelques jours dans les pages du figaro
nous avons besoin d'une forme d'union
sacrée pour résoudre les problèmes
industriels de l'immigration les
problèmes de santé que nous aurons une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
pour gouverner autrement je pense que
nous avons besoin non pas du parti uni
du président public mais d'une union
beaucoup plus large qui fasse appel à
des coalitions à des hommes et des
femmes qui ont l'expérience mais n'y
voyez pas uniquement un plaidoyer pro
domo et on n'a pas besoin nécessairement
d'un premier ministre
c'est un débat sur nos propres
institutions mais on voit bien que là
aussi je pense qu'il faudra mener ce
débat sur les institutions et si un jour
ou supprime le poste de premier ministre
ça veut dire qu'il faut un rééquilibrage
il faut des changements très profonds de
notre constitution qui donne davantage
de pouvoir de contrôle au parlement
manuel valls est notre invité ce matin à
l'ancien premier ministre en ce 11
novembre manuel valls daniel duigou
qu'est prêtre journaliste psychanalyste
qui vient d'ailleurs de sortir un livre
sept jours au désert aux éditions
salvator
daniel duigou qui est retiré dans un
ermitage à ouarzazate au maroc était de
passage à paris il a une question à vous
poser à propos de l'église et ce qui s'y
passe
manuel valls la société de demain se
transforme au point que nous ne pouvons
pas savoir ce que elle sera demain il ya
la nécessité d'inventer une nouvelle
société
l'église l'église de france qui est
partenaire de la société vient de
recevoir un un coup terrible avec le
rapport sauvé pensez vous qu'elle a
encore un avenir une parole pour
construire l'avenir de demain
par semestre des cultes ou des relations
avec les cultes et en même temps je
comme ministre de l'intérieur c'est
absolument et je suis très très très
respectueux de la séparation du pouvoir
et du rôle évidemment des dés que je
pense que l'être humain est ce qu'il est
il a besoin une forme de sacré une forme
de transcendance nous nous vivons avec
l'idée que nous allons mourir et en même
temps la vie est magnifique dont nous
avons besoin de philosophes nous avons
besoin de têtes dans une société on
puisse croire ne pas croire il ya des
cultes il y a dia il y à il y à des
églises et l'église de france mais
l'église en général parle de l'église
catholique se trouve face à un défi tout
à fait considérable mais elle est quand
même l'un des rares églises avoir fait
ce travail nécessaire indispensable par
rapport aux victimes des prêtres
pédophiles
grâce à la commission sauvé d'avoir fait
ce travail d'introspection mais
maintenant on lui demande à tous les
niveaux par rapport aux victimes par
rapport à ce qui peut se passer encore
aujourd'hui vous savez des choses qu'il
ya une peluche choqué par ce sont
évidemment les déclarations scandaleuses
du cardinal barbarin a toujours compris
pourquoi on n'a pas démissionné
immédiatement mais c'est que des prêtres
qui avaient été mis en cause ait été
envoyée ensuite pour les éloigner en
afrique et ça je parle à tv5 et ça pour
moi c'était un scandale effrayant et que
l'église ait tant tardé à peu la mettre
en cause juste la mettre en question en
espagne il n'y a pas eu de rapport
sauver l'église espagnole a semblé
vouloir mettre sous le boisseau a eu ces
problèmes-là est-ce que vous l'aviez
perçu quand vous êtes oui bien sûr en
espagne en italie au 6 mai en espagne
j'avais été frappé par le fait qu' on
avait l'impression que ces phénomènes
s'était arrêté aux pyrénées alors que
l'église espagnole peut pas porter
d'accusations général mais par exemple à
une emprise bien plus importante qu'en
france sur les enfants à travers l'école
elle a beaucoup de pouvoir beaucoup de
moyens beaucoup d'institutions
éducatives sous sa responsabilité
donc ce travail doit être faite sinon
sinon les institutions vous savez elles
sont périssables peuvent mourir est
notre invité ce matin merci denis carot
dans un instant d mèze korkmaz 2 tv5
monde sur ce bateau
de lot
jean manuel valls est la situation à la
frontière entre le bélarus et la pologne
ne cessent de se tendre
minsk appuie là où ça fait mal de fait
là l'union européenne est incapable de
s'entendre sur une politique commune de
l'asile quelle est votre position là
dessus est ce qu'il faut une politique
commune de l'immigration
il faut autour de nos frontières nos
frontières soient sur le protéger je
parlais de nos frontières communes des
frontières de l'union européenne
au delà la crise avec ce régime qui est
un régime totalitaire qui est déjà
sanctionné par l'union européenne qui
agit en plus derrière avec le soutien de
vladimir poutine au fond là on a et qui
agit de la manière la pire là cette fois
ci c'est s'il s'agit plus seulement de
la répression de ses opposants mais on
utilise les migrants il ya beaucoup
d'afghans mais pas seulement pour mettre
une pression sur l'union européenne donc
il faut être intransigeant vis-à-vis de
la biélorussie comme de la russie et il
faut aider comme nous l'avons fait avec
des pays baltes il y a quelques mois
aujourd'hui la pologne face à cette
pression on ira toi mais la plaine
réclament un mur réclament des barbelés
la pologne réclame que frontex ne soit
plus là à seulement à être juste un
observateur mais aussi à refouler est-ce
que je suis favorable à un renforcement
très net des moyens donnés aux pays et
donc aussi aux moyens communs de l'union
européenne pour que nos frontières
communes à l'est comme au sud soit
davantage
protégé je pense mais protégé ça veut
dire quoi il a vraiment peu plus passer
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut plus passer
la manière qu'on fait comme la plagne ça
veut dire qu'il faudra faire d'une
manière ou d'une autre comme la pologne
failli coûter moi je pense qu'on a
besoin d'un vrai débat j'allais dire
serein avec de la méthode je reconnais
que c'est difficile et que c'est un peu
idéaliste sur la question migratoire sur
quel type d'immigration nous a besoin
quel type de société voulons nous et
donc à partir de ce moment là je pense
qu'il faut une pause sur une politique
migratoire qu'il faut tout remettre à
plat
c'est vrai pour le regroupement familial
c'est vrai pour les mariages c'est vrai
pour l'accueil de l'immigration du
travail et donc il faut que nos
frontières communes soient davantage
protégés sinon il n'y aura pas d'europe
sinon le projet européen tons bruns de
lui-même le projet européen passe aussi
par une défense emmanuel macron va
organiser un sommet de la défense à
partir de janvier la france prend la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne est-ce qu'il faut aussi une
europe de la défense parce qu'il faut
des moyens communs en matière de défense
je reste sceptique même si ce débat tout
à fait passionnant parce que pour le
moment et jusqu'à maintenant c'est la
france parce que nous avons une armée
capable de projeter sur différents
continents parce que nous avons l'arme
nucléaire la dissuasion nucléaire parce
que nous avons une vision de notre rôle
dans le monde parce que c'est nous
donkey assumons davantage les
responsabilités parce que nous sommes
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité mais parce que nous assumons
ses responsabilités nous sommes en
capacité on devoir de demander aux
autres pays davantage de solidarité et
d'intervention et puis en effet d'avoir
une industrie du matériel commun des
missions communes c'est ça mon avis
l'étape indispensable qu'il faut
accomplir d'émettre leur place une
dernière question toujours sur cette
présidence tournante est ce que vous
pensez que 100 anglais merkel emmanuel
macron est capable de fédérer ou
d'incarner cette europe qui est un peu
en crise existentielle oui
incontestablement et puis bon c'est la
démocratie les dirigeants passent même
si la langue futilité de tanguer la
marque n'a été tout à fait remarquable
mais je pense que je qu'on appelle le
couple franco-allemand quoi qu'il arrive
fonctionnera sans les eaux nous ne
pouvons rien je pense notamment aux pays
aux pays fondateurs ou pays du sud
l'italie et l'espagne qui lui doivent
jouer un rôle tout à fait important mais
sans l'allemagne et la france l'europe
ne peut pas aller de l'avant donc cette
coopération se travaille avec des
leaderships bien évidemment et le
président français quel qu'il soit doit
exercer ce leadership et le discours d'
emmanuel macron il ya maintenant quatre
ans à la sorbonne avait marqué les
esprits et reste à mon avis une des
feuilles de route mais l'europe et
louette davantage protégés souveraine je
crois que c'est ça le mandat qui est
donné aux dirigeants européens pour les
années qui viennent une valse est ce que
vous auriez la tentation vous a entendu
sur les questions régaliennes tout à
l'heure toujours très présents dynamique
énergique de revenir au gouvernement
alors attendez pas comme ministre des
affaires étrangères comme l'ont été les
anciens premiers ministres mais comme
ministre de l'intérieur est ce que ça
vous plairait ce que l'idée vous
plairait même si vous ne pouvez pas
faire de réponse c'est évidemment compte
tenu du contexte politique non et puis
et puis parce que je ne suis pas en
situation puis parce que personne à part
vous et je vous en remercie yeux fait si
ça arrive est le 2 le demande mais moi
servir mon pays à assumer des
responsabilités après ça dépend comment
avec qui et dans quelles conditions
mais bien évidemment parce que j'ai
l'énergie j'ai le goût et parce que je
pense que sur ces sujets là on a évoqué
la lutte contre l'islamisme contre le
terrorisme et les questions de sécurité
parce que j'ai eu raison ou la montée de
l'antisémitisme jus raison avant d'eau
dont le oui parce que je pense que j'ai
toujours une énergie et des idées
claires sur ce fut là je suis prêt à
servir mais je peux le faire de
différentes manières dans l'action ou
dans le commentaire merci manuel valls
ancien premier ministre et puis bonne
cérémonie du l'ozone dans quelques
minutes vous serez au côté du président
de république et d autres anciens
premiers ministres sur les
champs-elysées merci dé m korkmaz on se
retrouve jeudi prochain en direct sur
tv5monde merci à tous bonne journée
[Musique]